come thank you so much for speaking with
Sky News you've talked about a
revolution effort what would it take to
deliver that in your view
two things one free and fair elections
we want people of Pakistan to decide who
governs them we don't want a bunch of
crooks imposed us on us by buying
loyalties of about 20 of our of our
members of parliament and spending about
20 30 million dollars and toppling a
government and known Crooks sixty
percent of cabinet is on bail so it we
want rights we want the same the
powerful to be brought under the law at
the moment there are two laws in
Pakistan one for the poor which don't
have access to Justice and the powerful
law above law how far are you willing to
go to deliver change
well it's a you know it's not politics
for me it's a mission you know someone
like me who the Almighty
blessed me with everything
I never had to go to politics and I
never would choose Politics as a career
but it was a mission that we want this
country to have Justice and law the rule
of law and my my contention is that
Prosperity comes after rule of law first
you have to establish the rule of law my
contention is that most of the
developing world is poor because they
don't have rule of law the government
are concerned about violence they've
talked about credible terrorist threats
are you worried about that
the only terrorist threat for us is the
government
and the handlers
we have no why would anyone want to uh
you know with families children women
you know if you see the people who are
with us why would anyone want to Target
them so it is just the government which
is petrified
the government is petrified of the
people they are petrified of Elections
because since I've been ousted from
Power
we've had 37 by-elections we have won 29
despite the government be supported by
the establishment the powerful
establishment you rarely ever win
against them the election commission is
totally biased despite that
we have 129 out of 37 so
last thing they want are elections and
what the country
wants our elections because right now
the political uncertainty is destroying
our economy because they are the
political uncertainty has led to
economic uncertainty and all economic
indicators are that we are heading down
so
there is only one way out of this person
there are free and fair elections
he raised the possibility of Bloodshed
do you think that likely uh what would
it take to stop this March there are
absolutely no reason why there should be
Bloodshed because
it is my right constitutional right to
protest peacefully I'm confident I'm
confident that and I've been on the road
for six months now
what I've seen I'm confident that I will
be able to direct it through elections I
will be able to direct this through
elections and bring about a change
but you know the other possibility is
you know you would not want it to go the
other way
your critics call you corrupt they say
you are in part responsible for some of
the economic woes of this country is
there anything that you would do
differently well firstly we inherited a
bankrupt country and all this is by the
way every Year's published the economic
survey of Pakistan where you have all
the
economic growth rate
industry
agriculture the growth rate and so on so
it's all documented every year
it's published all you have to do is see
what it was in 2018 country was bankrupt
despite two years of covid-19
in the in our third and fourth year it's
documented we in 17 years we had the
best economic growth rate of 5.7 and 6
percent where the highest exports in a
history Record highest tax collection in
our history we had highest remittances
in other words dollars coming in from
overseas pakistanis
uh
the agriculture was growing at four and
a half percent but this is an
agricultural country which is after 17
years the best agriculture growth
from that position
when we were removed the country
collapsed today we are heading towards
default
we will not be able to pay service our
debts Industries going down exports
going down remittances so where we left
that was the biggest conspiracy against
us and the reason why you see people
they see the difference
you know where the country was heading
there and now so just to be clear that
there is nothing different you would do
you roast
I would do one thing
I would not take power if I was at I had
a weak government like I had before it
was a coalition government
10 minority always I was not strong
enough to implement rule of law I could
not bring the powerful mafias under the
law because they were they would they
had all ways of weakening me or
blackmailing me so I would only take
power this time if I have the numbers in
in the National Assembly and if you are
strong enough in a parliamentary
democracy about the clear majority only
then can you implement rule of law which
I could not before
the election is less than a year away
why can't you wait
because
for us we are getting every day out of
uh 37 by elections we have 129
and every
the writing is on the wall for the whole
the entire opposition combined
stood against I I I took part in nine
nine elections nine elections just now
nine by-election and I stood on all we
can stand on all the seats a one man can
stand on all the seats
out of Nine the entire 13 party stood on
one side
with the establishment backing them the
powerful establishment
and I won out of nine eight of them
we have won 29 out of 37 by-elections so
it suits us because the government is
going down by the day which is why they
don't want to hold elections but the
country is going down
we are we are heading towards bankruptcy
towards default so for the sake of the
country the only way out is for the
economy to recover is to have political
stability that will only come through
elections when there's a stable
government then only can the economy
recover do you think given that you're
confident the elections will come early
do you think you'll be back in power
next year
I I feel that if they're free and fair
elections I mean any if you see any
polls in Pakistan you will see that my
my parties were ahead of all the other
parties put together so yes I feel if
their free elections will win but then
uh you know you never
I mean as a sports person I know that
until the match is over you you never
show
yes stamina and yes I never thought at
my age I would be doing this again
and no regrets no change it's full steam
ahead
hello no regrets I mean I
I have tried my best
um you know the country has given me so
much
I have more love and respect than any
other Pakistani in this country and so I
try my best you know for my country and
I know the only way out is justice that
the only way you can liberate people is
by giving them their rights and that
comes to rule of law which protects the
fundamental rights